good morning from rainy for you happy
for our plan for today is to get from
puppy to Cory I guess and it's our last
you hopefully we just had the most
uncomfortable rights on this whole trip
it's maybe a good idea to squeeze in
between motorcycles and bicycles
everything went numb and these are not
paved roads there's potholes everywhere
it's that we were just this bumpy ride
took us through the Bosque encantado
which is here but it's also very wet
it's still raining we're totally soaked
yeah we're waiting for the Sun now all
right guys we're again in the back of a
pickup truck and this time Salinas
family took us there spending over there
it's adorable
we came from it's quite exhausting once
this meter of elevation that was nice
but now it's time to head back down to
the valley to reassert occurs to you
good morning guys grab for going down to
the next village to her to review thank
you every day why are you checking and
rule number one about you checking never
do so on an empty stomach
alright we got dropped off we wanted to
be tonight and puerto rio tranquilo we
are back with Pato
who's down there preparing the boats so
we're back and say father how is it has
a beautiful